uh when you moved to Colorado is that
when you became friends with Hunter S
Thompson well we were yeah we were his
neighbor we were his closest neighbor
I'll tell you a very very funny story
about that
um we uh when I met my my future wife we
were dating at the time you know we
weren't married yet and uh we were
getting very serious and um I um we
we're living you know I was living in my
little condo I had this little condo out
there and uh we're thinking about buying
a house and um she's she comes from a
farm she grew up on a farm in Illinois
so she's always had tons of animals and
things like that so um she found this
piece of property out in Woody Creek
which is right outside Aspen and um you
know where it had a barn and could put
you know you could have animals etc etc
so the real estate agent was a really
good friend of mine we go out there and
we're standing on the property kind of
looking around and all of a sudden we
hear these two shotgun blasts
and then all of a sudden and the little
Barn that we were standing next to had a
metal roof and all of a sudden pellets
going
all over the all over the metal roof and
I'm like what the hell's going on he
goes oh that's your neighbor that's
that's that's the Hunter
don't don't worry about it he's fine and
I'm like okay I said wait a second I
said we're gonna move into a house
that's literally shotgun distance from
this guy no I think he's shooting no I'm
serious I think he knew that someone was
going to buy the property and he was
putting a shot across the bow you know
seriously you know metaphorically of
course
um yeah and I was like and he said no no
he's great man you don't know it won't
be a problem and so then over the years
we became friends and you know we'd go
about go up there and watch Monday Night
Football with him and the sheriff and
all that and uh yeah you know he was if
he liked you he was fantastic you know
and um he um he liked being Hunter you
know he liked he liked the slouch hat
with the cigarette holder and the
motorcycle and the big glass of you know
gin or whatever he was drinking
um but you know deep down inside he was
a southern he was he was from Kentucky
he was a southern gentleman and uh you
know we didn't see a lot of each other
but um and I you know we we went to his
funeral the one that Johnny Depp you
know put on where they shot his ashes
out of a cannon we were there for that
wow it was it was freaking crazy so yeah
even now we still have our house there
and if you drive out our lane you drive
directly into his driveway it just seems
like it'd be hard to talk to someone
like because they're kind of out there
and philosophical or was he more down
the Earth that you can easily carry a
conversation once you got to know him a
little bit
well you know you [ __ ] talk like this
you know guys
mumbled all the time you know it's funny
I I was asked to write this article
um uh for a magazine
you know in in Colorado or Aspen and
what had happened was in that little
Barn that we were thinking of buying his
Red Land Shark the one from Fear and
Loathing was in that barn and I said to
the real estate agent I said why is this
guy's car in someone else's property he
goes ah that's Hunters it just and he
had put a padlock on the door and it
wasn't his property and he said well
this is Woody Creek this is not like
other places he goes you'll get to
you'll figure this out so when time the
time came we were going to use this
little Barn as a kind of guest house
we're gonna convert it to an apartment
live there while we
um you know built the rest of the house
and so the keys were in the car so I
jump started it and I because I went to
his house knocked on his door he never
answered so I just pulled literally
pulled the car straight up in front of
his kitchen door and just left it there
and 20 years went by he never said a
word to me about it
I think he I think he just thought it
appeared you know just like appeared in
front of us yeah
no no it was great you know we um that's
cool yeah like I said we'd go up there
and watch Monday Night Football and I
got all kinds of stories